[Musique]
avril 2022 palais des congrès de
montréal c'est la grande rencontre
annuelle de l'industrie des fruits et
légumes ici fournisseur grossiste et
distributeur font leurs emplettes et
s'il des contrats pour l'année à venir
parmi ceux ci des géants de la banane
c'est tellement instruit une place
importante que c'est même plus considéré
comme un produit exotique
du mil est représente un des plus grands
distributeurs au canada elle est au
palmarès numéro un avec un pourcentage
de plus de 10 % des fruits consommés et
il ya cinquante autres fruits qui se
serrent
90%
[Musique]
fait étonnant la banane coûterait moins
cher en dollars d'aujourd'hui qui lie à
25 à un mystère que nous avons voulu
éclaircir
comment on est capable de maintenir un
prix aussi intéressant pour le
consommateur les méthodes
traditionnelles au niveau de la
production de bananes ont amené des des
productions évoluent nos positions des
4500 kg par hectare par semaine quand on
regardait il ya 20 ans on avait à peine
1200 1500 qu'est ce donc l'augmentation
de la production et des beaucoup à
contrôler les coûts même à les voir
diminuer
le deuxième aspect que les compagnies de
bananes contrôle c'est la logistique et
le transport les grandes sociétés
majeures de bananes possèdent leurs
propres navires qui leur permettent de
contrôler et d'avoir une stabilité au
niveau des coûts de transport
le troisième aspect c'est le besoin pour
les grandes chaînes d'avoir la banane
comme un cheval de troie le consommateur
moyen vaut pas se rappeler du prix que
paye et sont servis la semaine dernière
la banane et un indécis thème très
stable dont les consommateurs se
souviennent et effectivement les grandes
chaînes vont utiliser la banane pour
attirer les consommateurs en magasin
mais sans nécessairement perdent de
l'argent ils vont les vendre très près
du cou pour justement l'utiliser comme
on attire des abeilles avec du miel
mais ses bas prix cash ou triste réalité
tout n'est pas rose dans l'industrie de
la banane
dans une allée du salon l'équipe
majoritairement féminine dès qu'ils
fruits un des importateurs de bananes
équitables côtoient les dole del monte
et chiquita de ce monde ci ont payé en
dollars de 2022 le même prix qu on pays
en 1995 la banane conventionnelles
serait une et cinq indolore et cinq
cents la livre alors la banane a été
gardé très peu cher à l'épicerie pendant
trop longtemps et la différence de prix
entre eux ce qu'on devrait payer et ce
qu'on paye c'est un gouffre énorme qui
est payé par quelqu'un d'autre on n'a
rien de gratuit et c'est vraiment ce
comme si on demandait aux petits
producteurs ou travailleurs de
plantation de nous subventionner un
produit à travers leurs salaires
minables les conditions de travail
épouvantables fait un peu le produit le
plus important pour commencer à parler
mon équipe et il ya des problèmes très
complexes dans la chaîne la banane parle
de problèmes environnementaux très
graves
on parle de problèmes de droit du
travail
et qui bat depuis
[Musique]
filtré des tonnes des organismes de
justice sociale et de partenariat avec
les petits producteurs agricoles
avec le commerce est clairement temps de
remettre de façon beaucoup plus droite
la justice en a et travailleurs et il
reconnaître un prix juste du produit
j'ai été vraiment
basculé par un report qui est sorti
l'année dernière
qui décrit les conditions de travail sur
les plantations au guatemala
les gens travaillent en moyenne 60 8
heures semaine pour un tout petit peu
plus qu'un dollar us de l'heure
avec de l'harcèlement sexuel
verbale et conditions de travail
épouvantables
et pourtant rappelons nous que 40% des
bananes qui rentre au canada proviennent
du guatemala
le produit équitable assure un salaire
minimum et des conditions de travail
sécuritaire pour tous les travailleurs
des bananeraies on ne peut être contrôle
sur les salaires moyens payés dans des
pays d'amérique centrale même chose est
sûre ce que l'industrie de la banane
n'est pas différent de tous les autres
industries dans un pays donné
d'ailleurs même les multinationales
comme dole et del monte et produisent
des fruits équitables mais la demande
des épiceries pour les bananes
équitables est encore faible nous ce
qu'on veut c'est d'offrir une banane
kiwi coûte un peu plus cher mais auquel
on a on n'a pas à se soucier de ces
questions là et même si on parle de
pourcentage de plus en termes réels
c'est pas une si grande différence que
ça
nous consommons en moyenne 33 livres de
bananes par an c'est donc une différence
de moins de 20 $ annuellement c'est une
très petite différence pour un produit
qui a un impact important
en début de chaîne d'approvisionnement
d'ailleurs devant la récente flambée des
coûts sept pays producteurs de bananes
se sont réunis en janvier pour faire
front commun et exigé des prix plus
justes
mais on finit une déclaration commune
donc une lettre commune de demandes très
poussée très clair en bar l'union
européenne mais envers tous les
acheteurs de bananes bondir les prix ne
fonctionne pas on peut pas réussir à
survivre dans nos productions nationales
avec des prix aussi bas et ils font
référence aux mécanismes de prix de fait
on en a des calculs déjà fait par
fairtrade de ckoi les coûts de
production sont transparents son public
on peut s'ancrer sur quelque chose de
déjà fait on n'invente pas la roue
même si on consomme beaucoup moins de
bananes équitables qu'en europe les
ventes sont en constante croissance
juste l'an dernier celles ci ont
augmenté de 40 pour ça pour qu'on pense
plus large que juste l'emballage de nous
fruits légumes il faut qu'on pense à qui
les a produits sous quelles conditions
et comment est-ce qu'ils ont été payés
[Musique]